- You need to give away your citizenship.
(patriotic music)
- Today, I'm taking the
U.S. citizenship test.
- I'm not sure if I'm gonna pass.
- I sold my soul to AP
U.S. History for two years,
so I'm really hoping that I pass.
- So, I got naturalized
on September 24th, 2015.
I came from Taiwan.
- I moved here when I
was about 12 from India.
- I became an American citizen
in April 15th, last year.
And I am originally from
the Dominican Republic.
- So, when you took the test you couldn't,
you know, answer on paper?
- Oh my gosh
- This is not
- an open book question, you just have to
answer the question right there.
- Right there. Business.
- I think this test is easy.
- I took this test and I
passed with very good grades.
- I did grow up taking American history,
but I definitely did fresh
up on things before I went,
'cause I wanted to make sure I passed.
I think the test is easy.
- Oh goodness.
- I think I could do well on this.
- I think I know some about
American history and government.
- I think I know a good amount.
I'm not gonna say I'm an expert.
- Good luck.
- Thanks, I'm gonna need it.
- What is the name of the Speaker
of the House of Representatives now?
- It's a guy that I don't like,
but some people think he's cute.
- I don't know any good-looking
guys in the White House.
- Is it Mitch McConnell? (buzzer)
- Paul Ryan. (bell dinging)
- I don't know who that is.
- Name two National U.S. Holidays.
- Independence day. (bell dinging)
- Martin Luther King
Jr. Day? (bell dinging)
- Christmas (bell dinging)
and Halloween. (buzzer)
- Halloween is definitely
not a U.S. holiday.
- I don't know why I said that.
I panicked.
- When was the Declaration
of Independence adopted?
- I'm like scared, because I know
the general numbers for this
- You know it, you know it!
- I know a ton of odd numbers
- in it and it's four digits.
- July fourth, 1776. (bell dings)
- Yeah.
- 75? (buzzer) Oh no!
- The House of Representatives
has how many voting members?
- I feel like I know this.
- Glasses are fogging.
I'm getting nervous.
- 300. (buzzer)
- That times a million is how much money
I want in my bank account.
- 500. (buzzer)
- Alright.
- I'm gonna say 50. (buzzer)
- Is it gonna be like 435? (bell dings)
- Are you kidding me?
- Let's go! 3rd grade!
- Mrs. Murphy!
- Oh my god!
- This many people vote and yet we have
- Who is the Chief Justice
of the United States now?
- Chief Justice Sotomayor? (buzzer)
- They're probably like old and
white and male. (bell dings)
- It's John Roberts.
- I wouldn't have known
that, so I'm not upset.
- Just tell me a very very white name.
- A very white name?
Bob Jones? (buzzer)
- (laughing) It's kind of close.
- How many U.S. senators are there?
- I'm gonna say 50 on this one. (buzzer)
- 52. (buzzer)
- No wait, because it's two per state
- Yes.
- And there's 50 states.
- Crap.
- Who was president during World War I?
- Wait actually there were two Roosevelts,
so I guess Roosevelt? (buzzer)
- Did you know this?
- Yes.
- You got it right? Wow.
- Which one?
- Franklin. (buzzer)
- No, it was not that one.
- It was Teddy?
- No, na-no. (laughing)
- Was it Woodrow Wilson? (bell dings)
- Yay! That was good.
- It's cause that was a history question,
the rest are like current events questions
which I steer so clear of.
- You passed. (bell dings)
- Yay. America!
(buzzer)
- Give back your passport.
- What?
- (buzzer) Is Donald Trump gonna see this?
Am I gonna be deported?
- The questions that you got wrong were
about the government, and I thought that
everyone knew about the government.
I guess not.
- I always joke about how I know more
American history than
natural born Americans, so
- I can't get mad at you.
- Most of the questions I
got wrong were about people
who are in the government,
and I'm not as familiar
as I probably should be with that.
This is my country.
I live here.
- I don't judge myself for missing some
of the very current
questions, 'cause I think,
like a lot of people,
I'm trying to pretend
politics don't exist right now.
- When I took it, I thought it was easy,
but only it was easy
because I studied a lot.
- I guess I'm gonna have to
study up on my U.S. history.
- And I'm going to try to be
more open to understanding
and learning about who's
running our country.
- You need to know a
lot to get into America
and the restrictions are
getting harder and harder.
I took my citizenship for granted today.
(patriotic music)